Okay Michael, so the second algorithm that we're going to
look at it just like principle components analysis, except it's
called independent components analysis. Okay, and the major difference is
really the difference between the first word principle and independent.
So the main idea here is that PCA is about
finding correlation. And the way it does that is by
maximizing variance. And what that gives you, is the ability
to do reconstruction. What independent components analysis is doing, or
often called ICA by those in the know, is it's trying to maximize independence.
Very simply put, it tries to find
a linear transformation of your feature space, into
a new feature space, such that each of the individual new features are mutually
independent and I mean that in a
statistical sense. So, you are converting your XI,
your X1, X2, XI... And there's some new features space let's call it I don't
know let's call it a Y, Y1,Y2 YI... Such that each
one of the new features are statistically independent of one another, that is
to say their mutual information is equal to zero. Does that make sense?
>> And
this is going to be a linear transformation?
>> It's going to be a linear transformation.
>> T, to make them statistically independent.
>> So, I find some linear transformation here, which is going to take my
original feature space, which I'm representing with
these X's, and transform it into a
new feature space, such that, if I were to treat each of these new
features as random variables and compute their
mutual information, I would get for all
pairs a mutual information of zero. That's part one and
the second thing that it's trying to do is that
it's trying to make certain that the mutual information between
all of the features, y and the original feature space x
is as high as possible. So in other words, we
want to be able to reconstruct the data. We want
to be able to predict an X from a Y and a Y from a X. While at the same time
making sure that each of the new dimensions is in
>> fact mutually independent. In a statistical sense.
>> I think I'm going to need an example.